Let's do a few more examples
with the ideal gas equation.
So we have pressure times volume
is equal to the number
of molecules we have in moles
times the ideal gas constant
times temperature in Kelvin.
And I just got a comment on one
of the videos saying it
made sense except for the fact
that R seems kind of like this
mysterious thing in here.
And the way you think about R--
let me rearrange this a
little bit.
Let me write it as pressure
times volume is
equal to R times nT.
So we've established, or
hopefully we've established,
the intuition that the pressure
times the volume
should be proportional to
essentially the total energy
we have in the system.
Temperature is average energy,
or energy per molecule, and
this is the total number
molecules we had.
What R is, the ideal gas
constant is, when you multiply
moles times Kelvin, you
get mole Kelvin.
And with pressure times volume,
it's force per area
times the volume.
You get force times distance,
or force times one dimension
of distance, which is joules,
so this is in joules.
So what the ideal gas constant
essentially does is it
converts-- we know that this is
proportional to this, but
it sets the exact constant of
proportionality and it also
makes sure we get the units
right, so that's all it is.
It just helps us translate
from a world dealing with
moles and Kelvins to a world of
dealing with, well, in this
case, atmospheres and liters,
or bars and meters cubed, or
kilopascals and meters cubed.
But no matter what the units of
the pressure and the volume
are, the whole unit of pressure
times volume is going
to be joules.
So it's just a translation
between the two and we know
that they're proportional.
Now, with that said, let's
do some more problems.
So let's say we want to know
how many grams of oxygen.
So we want to know
grams of O2.
So how many grams of O2 are in
a 300-milliliter container
that has a pressure of 12
atmospheres and the
temperature is 10
degrees Celsius?
Well, we've already broken out
our ideal gas equation.
Let's see, pressure
is 12 atmospheres.
So we can say 12.
I'll keep the units there.
12 atmospheres times
the volume.
The volume should be in
liters, so this is 300
milliliters, or 300 thousandths
or 3 tenths.
So that's 0.3 liters.
300 one thousandths of a
liter is 0.3 liters.
And that is equal to the number
of moles we have of
this, and that's what we
need to figure out.
If we know the number of moles,
we know the number of
grams. So this is equal
to n times R.
Now which R should we use?
We're dealing with liters
and atmospheres.
We'll deal with this one.
Liters, atmospheres,
mole-Kelvin, 0.082.
Times 0.082.
And what's our temperature?
It's 10 degrees Celsius.
We always have to do everything
in Kelvin.
So it's 283 degrees Kelvin.
So all we have to
solve for is n.
We just have to divide both
sides of this equation by this
right here, and so we have n is
equal to 12 atmospheres--
I'm just swapping the sides--
times 0.3 liters divided by
0.082 times 283 degrees.
Our answer will be in moles.
And if you want to verify that,
you can plug in all the
units and use units for the
ideal gas constant.
The number of moles we're
dealing with, so it's 12 times
0.3 divided by 0.082
divided by 283 is
equal to 0.155 moles.
Now how many grams are in one
mole of an oxygen molecule?
So one mole of O2, well, we
know oxygen's atomic mass.
It's 16.
One molecule of oxygen, of
gaseous oxygen, has two atoms
in it, so it has an
atomic mass of 32.
So it's molar mass, it's mass
per mole, is going to be 32
grams.
Now we don't have one mole.
We have 0.155 moles.
So to figure out how many grams
we have, we multiply 32
grams per mole times
0.155 moles, and
we'll get our answer.
So let's do that.
So we have 32 times 0.155 is
equal to 4.96 grams, or
roughly 5 grams. So we have
approximately 5 grams of
molecular oxygen.